تقويه طرابلس عام صعبا يضاف الى عوام
الازمه الليبيه شهدت فيه المدينه احداثا
كثيره وبينما تستقبل العاصمه العام الجديد
اتمنى سكانها العيش بسلام بعيدا عن شبه
الحروف
اكثر من 70 شخصا لقو حدفهم في ازقه طرابلس
خلال العام 20 22 بسبب الاشتباكات بين
التشكيلات المسلحه داخل المدينه لاسباب
سياسيه او حتى لاعاده ترسيم مناطق النفوذ
بينها واقع عكر صفوى الحياه في المدينه
يقعدوا فيك
نفس البرنامج ما في حاجه جديده
يكون خير باذن الله
والخدمي دفع سكان عاصمه البلاد للتظاهر في
الشوارع في اوقات مختلفه من الان مطالبين
بجراء الانتخابات ورحيل جميع الاجسام
السياسيه وتحسين الوضع المعيشي
الحقيقه
[موسيقى]
التوحيد الليبيين مع بعضهم كلمه واحده
رغم ما تعانيه لعاصمه الليبيه من صعونانيه
وخدميه الا ان المناشطه الثقافيه والفنيه
لم تغيب عنها فكانت المدينه عاصمه الاعلام
العربي واختتم عامها لحضور شخصيات عربيه
الرسميه وفنيه وثقافيه ضمن فعاليات ايام
طرابلس الاعلاميه منير الاشهب طرابلس
العربيه